that's what it must have sounded like
when Belgian special police forces
stormed Unni reporters apartment on
October 7th 2018 you know they're just
cool amber see they came in through here
forcefully pushed me to the far end of
the room when I opened the door I was
flung against the piano and they twisted
my hands behind my back Montaigne
Pinocchio matinee you know they don't
swallow year the singer was sheltering
two unregistered Sudanese refugees at
the time this is where they slept the
Belgium police unit accused a porter of
people smuggling which left her
speechless they told me you are under
arrest you no longer have any rights be
silent the whole situation was one long
violent ordeal I was wearing my pajamas
a female police officer dressed me I
couldn't even cry at that moment only
later her computer and telephone were
seized to check whether she was working
with Belgian people smugglers the 45
year old was handcuffed and led out of
her home while her neighbors were
watching where does human compassion end
and where does people-smuggling begin we
meet a lawyer who defends many Belgium's
who acted just like dunya deported her
and are now accused of people
trafficking he says the authorities are
abusing their power it is simply
unacceptable that the police and public
prosecutors are going after ordinary
citizens raiding their homes at 5:00 in
the morning is an abuse of power there
might be grounds to call in and question
citizens but that entails ringing the
doorbell criminals become the dominant
this is Brussels Park Maximilian where
refugees flock who have no place to
sleep and don't get regular meals we
want to know how their life has changed
now that many Belgian citizens are too
scared to put them up for a few nights
because of fear they are committing a
crime the refugees want to remain
anonymous user is from Eritrea he says
he doesn't know where to sleep at night
which makes braving the cold winter
temperatures even harder how is your
situation at the moment where do you
sleep at night here in the park do you
have a blanket yes I do we all sleep
here my friends to Belgium Parliament is
deeply divided over how to treat
migrants until recently the right-wing
nationalist new flemish alliance party
determined the government's tough stance
on migrants until it quits the coalition
in protest over the UN migration pact
what's their take on the current
situation we requested an interview -
but never received a reply
dunja de porter was forced to spend 24
hours in solitary confinement until a
judge ruled she was innocent
the ordeal has scarred her for life it
will take a long time for her to regain
trust in people so that some day she may
feel strong enough to again help others
you
[Music]